what if I was completely authentic with
my own pain
I stopped with all the and and
stopped with trying to be anything else
other than let me write something that
is very authentically myself
I sat down to write this film about
grief and about loss but also about how
one stands back up
as a writer this is what's gurgling
inside of you and when you sit down and
stare at the blank cursor to see what's
going to come out this is what came out
uh writing is sitting alone at a
blinking cursor telling yourself you
suck so I would say develop very early
on a system that is Fail-Safe for you
working and producing
content
and that is in in 2023 that is very much
turning off your Wi-Fi and getting your
phone out of the room it's about putting
your butt in the chair and not being
afraid to not know what it is today but
getting in the chair and showing up